Hallo Leute, mir tut immer noch das Bein weh, fast eine Woche, also eigentlich ist es nicht das Bein, es ist halt so unten am Bein, Schienbein, aber es ist besser, obwohl ich gestern Rennen war, also wer weiß, was das ist.
Moin Lukas, hast du Best-Practice-Tipps zum Schreiben von Docker-Files? Fällt mir so spontan nichts ein, in den Git-Repo einchecken, aber das hat ja mit dem Docker-File selbst nichts zu tun.
Ja, Oil ist relativ spät, ich hab echt keine Ahnung, was mir da, da fragst du mich was, fällt mir so spontan nichts ein.
Ach ja, doch, Multistage-Builds.
Multistage-Builds, also verwende Multistage-Builds, wenn möglich, das sage ich immer möglich.
Also Multistage-Build heißt, du lässt nicht alles, was du während der Build-Time brauchst, auch in deinem finalen Image drin.
Multistage-Builds.
Was ist heute geplant? Ich hatte nichts besseres zu tun, bin angekommen, nix.
Weißt du, was ich meine?
Multistage-Builds.
Also Multistage-Builds sind POG.
Du kannst im Endeffekt drei, vier Build-Steps haben mit deinem Image und am Ende kommt dann irgendein Binary raus und dann machst du ein finales Image, wo nur das Binary reinkommt und dann hast du, ja, ein Mini-Image.
Ach ja, und, und, seriously, das mag nicht Best-Practice sein, das mag vielleicht mal ein persönlicher Geschmack sein.
Nimm nicht Alpine, nimm irgendein Minimal-Debit.
Ist jetzt auch nicht so viel größer, schon größer ist nicht so viel größer, hat aber einige Probleme von Alpine nicht.
Zum Beispiel hast du keine Probleme mit teilweise DNS-Auflösungen und solchen Geschichten.
Wie gesagt, das ist kein Best-Practice.
Viele Leute schwören auf Alpine, ich nicht.
Das macht gar keinen so großen Unterschied.
Wenn du Multistage-Builds verwendest und dann irgendein Minimal-Debian oder so nimmst, irgendein Slim-Debian, Bookworm, Slim.
Was immer, dann ist das, ich weiß nicht, was der Unterschied ist, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es die paar MB ausmachen.
Übermorgen-Zwischenprüfung, ist doch nice.
Weißt du, du hast fast geschafft, also die Halbzeit, ne?
Du hast quasi mehr Zeit geschafft, als mehr Zeit noch übrig.
So musst du es sehen.
Aber mach dir noch keine Gedanken um die Zwischenprüfung, Zwischenprüfung ist easy.
Solange du, ich mach mal kurz Package ab.
Solange du ordentlich, ich weiß, dass die mittlerweile in die Endnote eingeht, aber mach dir keine Gedanken, solange du ordentlich die alte Prüfung angeguckt hast, ist easy.
Leute, macht euch keine Gedanken, die Zwischenprüfung, die IHK-Prüfung sind einfach.
Es geht bei den IHK-Prüfungen, das muss man sich immer überlegen, es geht bei den IHK-Prüfungen nicht um fachliches Know-How.
Das hat zwar oberflächlich den Anschein, hat es aber nicht.
Jeder Noob-Schein.
Jeder Noob-Schein, der die IHK-Prüfung macht, wenn er versteht, wie die IHK Fragen stellt und was die IHK für Antworten haben will.
Ihr könnt der krasseste Informatiker-Hackerman sein, wenn ihr noch nie eine IHK-Prüfung gemacht habt, werdet ihr verkacken.
Und ihr könnt der fachfremdeste BWL-Dude sein, wenn ihr euch zwei Monate auf die Prüfung vorbereitet habt, schafft ihr die.
Also so aussagekräftig ist die Abschlussprüfung, beziehungsweise die Zwischenprüfung, die IHK-Prüfung.
Die IHK-Prüfung ist easy.
Wenn ihr noch zusätzlich Ahnung habt und euch ein bisschen...
vorbereitet, dann ist das wirklich gar kein Problem, dass es extrem viel ist und es keinerlei Eingrenzung gibt.
Doch, du kannst das eingrenzen, indem du dir anguckst, was die letzten Jahre drangekommen ist.
Die IHK-Prüfungen sind zu 70% immer das gleiche.
Ich mach mal kurz Package-Updates.
Die IHK-Prüfungen sind immer der gleiche Shit.
70%.
Neu-Spiegel-DVD-Doku.
Das System IHK.
Würde ich mich sogar zu interviewen lassen.
Wie, es gibt keine Aure?
Package-Updates.
Was ist denn da los?
Ich verwende Arch, by the way, damit ich täglich 5x updaten kann.
Und jetzt kann ich nicht 5x updaten.
Das gefällt mir aber nicht.
Oh nein.
Ich hab meine Form wieder kaputt gemacht.
Irgendwas habe ich hier installiert,
dass es komplett
ultra rumspackt,
sobald ich track...
tracke mit der Maus.
Das ist total im Arsch.
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist,
aber es ist komplett kaputt.
Das ist irgendeine VMware-Geschichte.
Irgendeine VMware-Geschichte.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Das habe ich auf meinem anderen
Windows-Account mit VMware-Werkzeichen
gar nicht. Da kann ich tracken und robben,
wie ich will, und das ist nicht kaputt.
Ne, das ist noch VMware 17.
Aber...
Ne, ich hab noch nicht geupdatet.
Ne, das ist es nicht.
Ich mach kein Update auf 17.5.
Ne, habe ich auch nicht vorgehabt.
Aber das ist echt weird.
Das habe ich manchmal.
Wofür die Windows-ME
vor allem dieser übrig geblieben.
Dieser
übrigbleibsel. Massive.
Allerdings danke, Leute,
für die Subs letztens.
Ich hab wieder nicht richtig reingeguckt.
Yes, son.
Mr. Amec hat subscribed vor einer Minute.
Dankeschön.
Play auch am Start. Huge, Leute.
Das Ding gestern vergessen.
Herr Schocker.
Auch am Start. Den2Dev auch wieder da.
Darkseid hat gestern subscribed.
Alle sind irgendwie wieder
übersehen. Oder glaube ich zumindest,
dass ich übersehen habe.
Zatch.
Oh. Ich hab
saumäßig wenig Subs gerade.
Also das
macht schon was aus, ob man regelmäßig
streamt oder nicht. Ich habe in letzter Zeit kaum
gestreamt.
Und Instant...
Naja, gut. Ich meine, warum sollte man auch
Subs verlängern für jemanden, der nicht streamt?
Das macht ja keinen Sinn.
Würde ich auch nicht machen.
Ich habe heute Mittag wieder was mega ungesundes gegessen.
Und zwar...
Und auch noch viel.
Also nicht einfach nur ungesund,
sondern auch noch viel ungesund.
Tintenfischringe.
Also frittierte Tintenfischringe.
Mit Pommes frites.
Und so
Dipsoße.
Zwei Teller voll.
Und es liegt mir immer noch im Magen.
Ich merke das immer noch, ey.
Keine Subs heißt bald
Insi-Modus. Ja, korrekt.
Also alle subscriben, wenn wir
den Insi-Modus abwenden wollen.
Noch eine. Und was war das
ungesunde? Gab es Cola dazu? Ne, Wasser.
Wasserbeste.
Noch eine. Alles halt fettig wie Sau.
Ja. Und eigentlich nix
wirklich gutes dran.
Noch eine andere Frage.
Kennst du eine Lösung, womit man seine GitLab CI-Config
testen kann, ohne seine Commit-History
zu zerschießen? Hä?
Das verstehe
ich nicht.
Du meinst Custom-Pipelines? Die Config
für die Custom-Pipelines?
Dass du immer wieder neu pushen musst,
dass du siehst, ob es funktioniert?
Gar nicht. Einfach
Force pushen.
Armenten, Force pushen.
Du bist ja der Admin von dem Repo eindeutig,
wenn du CI-Geschichten einrichtest.
Armenten, Force pushen.
Da hast du immer nur einen Commit.
Also, so würde ich das machen.
Mozzarella-Sticks sind auch nice.
Wird mal wieder Zeit für einen
Placement-Speedrun? Dazu müsste ich erstmal
ein YouTube-Video machen.
Ja, DarkSide, was hältst du davon?
Armenten, Force pushen.
Das ist doch das Einfachste.
So, jetzt nochmal gucken,
ohne dass ich meine 4M kille.
Gibt's Updates hier.
Leute, wisst ihr,
was wir uns unbedingt mal zusammen angucken müssen?
Wir müssen uns zusammen mal
NixOS angucken. Einfach nur,
weil's geht. Ich hab letztens
ein Video geguckt, wo irgendjemand gesagt
hat, es ist zwar unglaublich,
aber stellt euch vor,
der hat gesagt, er ist von 8-Schlinux
umgestiegen
auf
NixOS.
Das glaub ich zwar erst, wenn ich sehe,
ich geh nicht davon aus, dass ich in nächster Zeit
auf irgendwas umsteigen werde.
Aber das, was der in dem Video
erzählt... Ich calle auch
Fake. Ja, ich glaub dem
das nämlich auch nicht.
Ich glaub dem, dass
dem Video tut es nämlich auch nicht.
Aber ich fand das ganz interessant, was der in dem
Video erzählt hat.
Dass du zum Beispiel auch
bei einem Upgrade, was fehlschlägt, zurückrollen
kannst, es dann immer noch geht.
Und dass es im Endeffekt eigentlich,
kein, wie soll man sagen,
so lebendes Betriebssystem ist,
sondern reproduzierbar
sich nach jedem Reboot quasi selbst
wiederherstellen kann, anhand einer
zentralen Config. Die Config sah
ein bisschen weird aus, so nach dem Motto
sogar meine
X-Config
und I3-Config müsste in der
Main-Config sein und so. Ein bisschen komisch
ist das Ganze schon, aber
angucken kann man sich's mal.
Ist das wie ein
Docker-Image als OS?
Wie's funktioniert weiß ich nicht.
Da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, wie's
im Hintergrund funktioniert.
Home-Manager hab ich gesehen, aber wenn schon machen wir gleich
NixOS. Home-Manager ist quasi
der NixOS-Package-Manager ohne
NixOS. Also
wie's funktioniert weiß ich nix.
Max, wann gehst du mal wieder
ins Stadion zur Eintracht?
Ich war einmal in
äh, guck sie, dankeschön für den Zap.
Ich war einmal in meinem Leben
bei einem Fußballspiel und das
war tatsächlich bei der Eintracht.
Das ist aber schon ewig her.
Damals hieß das Ding noch
Waldstadion.
Das letzte Mal,
als ich in dem Stadion war und ich hab
vergessen wie's heißt, das hatte ja schon
zwei, drei Namen die letzten Jahre über.
Was ist es mittlerweile?
Commerzbank Arena? Nee, das ist es
auch nicht mehr. Dings Park?
Irgendwas mit Park oder so?
Deutsche Bank Park.
Ja, also da war ich
tatsächlich
letztes...
nein, vorletztes Jahr
bei Chainlaw Park.
Ja, da war ich, da war ich schon.
Also, da war ich vorletztes Jahr
bei Iron Maiden in
Frankfurt und
da wäre ich besser nicht hingegangen
aus zwei Gründen.
Erstens
irgendwie schafft es
keine Location in Frankfurt
gescheiten Sound hinzukriegen.
Aber es war trotzdem nice. Und zweitens
habe ich mit Corona angefangen dabei.
Und das ist eigentlich der Hauptgrund, warum ich da besser
nicht hingegangen wäre.
Warum? Nein, die History ist doch nicht zu geschissen,
wenn du amendest und Force pusht.
Das ist doch gerade der Witz da dran.
Du hast keine Git History
damit. Du amendest immer
deine Changes und Force pusht. Du hast genau
ein Comet. Und das
andere löscht du wieder quasi.
Überschreibst du damit. Du bist, du bist ja
offensichtlich Admin dieses Repos, wenn du
CI-Geschichten einrichtest.
Kannst du es auch so machen.
Amenden, Force pushen. Amenden, Force pushen.
Oder aber
du machst deine History eklig
bis es funktioniert
und dann machst du ein Reset
und machst ein ordentliches Comet.
Nachdem du Admin des Repos
bist, kannst du rumsauen in jedem
Branch wie du willst. Das könnte
ganz... Oh, sadge Leute.
Wisst ihr was gerade gewesen ist?
Meine Tür hat gerade so
komisch geknackst.
Und ich wollte gerade sagen...
Oh, ich glaub meine Katze ist
bestimmt an der Tür und will rein.
Sadge.
Poltergeist bestimmt.
Meinst du sowas wie Gitlaps...
Das ging nicht an mich.
Fear of the Dark.
Ja.
Ich bin ja immer noch der Meinung, es heißt
Fear of the Duck.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du öfters Iron Maiden hörst.
Du kannst es jetzt nicht mehr, nicht mehr
nicht hören.
Es hört sich an, als würde der jedes Mal singen.
Fear of the Dark.
Max, ich muss dich mal was
fragen. Kennst du
gute Kubernetes Monitoring Lösungen?
Da ist die große Preisfrage.
Was willst du
eigentlich genau
monitoren?
Also willst du wirklich den Zustand von
deinem Cluster monitoren?
Willst du den Zustand von deinen
Nodes monitoren? Willst du irgendwelchen
State Content im Cluster monitoren?
Oder willst du die
Anwendungen überwachen, die in
deinen Pods im Cluster laufen?
Willst du zum Beispiel Log-Analyse
machen oder sowas?
Die einfachste Variante,
also aus meiner Sicht, die einfachste
Variante
easy, simples
Kubernetes Monitoring zu machen ist,
guck mal, was der Cloud-Anbieter
deiner Wahl anbietet, um
Alerts zu setzen für
Logs.
Also bei Google Cloud ist es zum Beispiel so,
dass alle Logs von deinen Pods
automatisch in diesen, boah fragt mich
nicht, wie das heißt, in dieses Log-Bucket
bei Google irgendwie reinkommen
und das kannst du dir dann auch
in der Web-Oberfläche mit dem Log-Explorer
angucken. Der Log-Explorer ist scheiße, der ist
lahm und laggy, aber ist ganz okay,
aber du kannst Alerts
setzen, wenn er bestimmte
Log-Einträge findet
oder ich glaube, man kann auch irgendwie
Negativ-Sachen irgendwie setzen, wenn er
bestimmte Log-Einträge nicht findet oder sowas,
dann kannst du dir einen Alert schicken lassen.
Das ist die simpelste integrierte
und einfachste Variante,
einen groben Überblick zu behalten, was
an den Services gerade funktioniert und
was nicht und wo es Probleme gibt.
Guck dir an,
was dein jeweiliger Cloud-Anbieter
unterstützt.
Bei Azure weiß ich es aus dem Kopf
nicht, ist jetzt schon über
ein Jahr her oder ja, ein Jahr her,
wo ich da zuletzt mit rumgewurscht habe, hauptsächlich
bei mir ist es aktuell Google Cloud. Google hat
das, deswegen würde ich sagen, AWS
und Azure hat das bestimmt auch.
Bei Google
ist es einfach, du gehst dort,
wo der Log-Explorer hin ist, dann gibt es
irgendwo links unten gibt es sowas wie
Notifications und Alerts,
da klickst du drauf, dann kannst du
Notifications anlegen
und dann kannst du so
Queries aus dem Log-Explorer reinpasten,
sobald er was findet, kann er dich über
verschiedene Channels benachrichtigen,
zum Beispiel, das Simpelste ist
wahrscheinlich eine E-Mail schicken, auch im Jahr
2024, ja. Ansonsten
ist das Thema
Kubernetes Monitoring
natürlich ein Fass ohne Boden.
Ich finde aber, man muss es
nicht übertreiben, sondern man muss sich überlegen, was
braucht man?
Meinung zu Health Checks I.O., kann man
auch verwenden, wenn man wirklich nur wissen
will, respondet irgendwie
ein Service, wobei Health Checks I.O.
doch eher was ist, um
nicht wirklich intern für dich
zu monitoren, sondern eher
sowas in Richtung
Status Page, so nach dem
Motto, Service ist weg, ich schreib mal eine
schöne Message,
was denn gerade
Sache ist und sowas.
Meinung zu OpenTelemetry, nice Sache,
ich hab mich noch nicht so
wirklich, also gerade aus
Programmiertechnischer Sicht, wollte ich mich da
in .NET mal mit beschäftigen, noch
nicht so sehr damit beschäftigt.
Außer ein paar Guides angeguckt, im Tutorial
für ASP.NET Core
angeschaut, aber zu wenig, dass
ich da jetzt irgendwie meinen Senf zu
abgeben könnte. Was halt cool ist,
dass du sehr nice Tracen kannst,
durch deine Anwendung durch.
So,
eine Sache muss ich
jetzt aber noch dazu sagen, wie gesagt,
generell Monitoring ist ein Fass ohne Boden.
Aus meiner persönlichen
Erfahrung hat sich
gezeigt, dass viele Läden,
also das war damals beim
Provider so, das war bei der Bank
so, das ist bei der Versicherung so,
dass extremes Overmonitoring
beschreib ich das mal, passiert,
aber im Umkehrschluss nichts
damit gemacht wird. Also es wird in
enorm viel collected an
Daten und es wird enorm
viel gemonitort, aber so
gut wie nichts davon gelangt
jemals in irgendeine
Alert-Regel. Und muss ich halt mal
überlegen, monitoren, nur um des
Monitorens willen, ist unsinnig.
Was sich beim Monitoring
interessiert, ist eigentlich der Alert.
Das ist das, was
meiner persönlichen Meinung
immer ein bisschen
zu kurz kommt. Eigentlich muss man sich
überlegen, wann will ich
Bescheid wissen?
Was ist das, was mich
interessiert, wenn es kaputt geht?
Wann will ich Bescheid wissen?
Ja, man kann nicht immer an
alle Sachen denken und manchmal ist es
sicherlich nicht verkehrt, ein bisschen
mehr einzusammeln, als zu wenig.
Aber was ich
oft gesehen habe ist, es wird auf
jeder Linux-Kiste ein Agent installiert,
es werden erstmal alle Default-Sachen
eingeschaltet,
es wird collected, was das Zeug
hält, dann explodieren dir deine
Storage-Dinger.
Jede Suche ist super
langsam, weil du 30 Millionen Sachen
sammelst am Tag
und du machst damit am Ende nichts.
Und ganz ehrlich, diese ganzen
out-of-the-box-Templates, die es
bei vielen Monitoring-Tools gibt,
halte ich persönlich wenig von.
Gerade wenn man das Thema Kubernetes
Monitoring sich anguckt,
da sind dann ganz merkwürdige
Default-Checks teilweise drin.
RAM-Auslastung über 16%.
Da denke ich mir, ja und? Da kriege ich
wenigstens was für mein Geld.
Habe ich letztens bei Checkmk gesehen,
Node-Auslastung über 16%
Warning.
Und? So what?
Ist doch gut.
Der Node macht wenigstens was für sein Geld.
Das habe ich auch nicht genau
verstanden, warum das da drin ist.
Da gibt es natürlich eine Ausnahme,
wenn es um Anwendungsmetriken
geht, wo
einen der Trend interessiert.
Dann kann man möglichst viele Daten
sammeln, allerdings dann auch nicht
alles.
Wisst ihr zum Beispiel, was ich gesehen habe?
Im letzten Laden, wo ich gearbeitet habe,
die sind irgendwann auf die Idee gekommen,
wir machen Prometheus Monitoring
nicht nur für
Logs,
Schwachsinn, jetzt habe ich Logs
im Chat gelesen und sage Logs.
Wir machen Prometheus Monitoring nicht nur
für Metriken,
wir machen Prometheus Monitoring für alles.
Dann haben die NodeExporter installiert,
SNMP Forwarder,
ähm,
die Anwendungen wurden weiterhin gecrawled.
Das ist explodiert,
die Prometheus Datenbank.
Und am Ende wurde so gut wie nichts alertet
davon.
Der NodeExporter,
guck mal,
es ist ja auch alles am Start,
der Standard
Prometheus NodeExporter,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob das bei denen auf der Webseite steht,
der collectet alles.
Da hast du dann so Dinger wie
SystemD, das ist auch so ein Teil,
wo ich mich aufregen kann, also nicht
SystemD.
Denke mal, die 16%
Node RAM
ist für das Downscalen der Nodes praktisch.
Du meinst, wenn du
dein NodePool verkleinerst, ja,
okay, vielleicht.
Aber,
der NodePool war noch auf Minimum.
Der war auf 4 Nodes, das ist,
kleiner geht's gar nicht.
Das ist halt das Problem
an Default Checks, das mag durchaus sinnvoll
sein, im Fall der Fälle.
Aber halt nicht so pauschal.
Zumindest,
da sammelst du dann so Dinger ein,
wie SystemD.
So, da hast du dann zig Metriken über irgendwelche
gestoppten und gestarteten Services
und irgendwann
kriegst du dann komische
Meldungen, weil
irgendein
SystemD Service
bei Wartungsarbeiten
gestoppt wurde und
keiner mehr weiß, wo man irgendwo
ist oder
bei Prometheus eintragen muss.
Und dann hast du irgendwie
auf einmal 500 Nachrichten,
weil irgendwelche SystemD...
Es ist sinnlos.
Um es mal kurz zu machen,
Overmonitoring ist übertrieben.
Und selbst wenn man Metriken collectet,
finde ich es auch nicht sinnvoll,
alle Metriken zu collecten, die irgendwelche
Tools anbieten,
sondern wirklich das, was einen
interessiert. Manchmal weiß man es nicht, manchmal
schadet es nicht, aber wenn man
so Trends
analysieren will, also wenn man zum Beispiel
gucken will, wie
eingeloggte User
zu offenen Connections, zu RAM-Auslastungen
sind und sowas in der Richtung.
Ist ja alles sinnvoll,
das in Metriken einzusammeln, aber
man muss es nicht übertreiben.
Also das Wichtigste, und damit
lassen wir es jetzt auch mal gut sein, das Wichtigste, was man sich
beim Monitoring überlegen muss, ist der Alert.
Bei was oder vor was
habe ich Angst,
oder bei was will ich benachrichtigen?
Gibt es auch eine Möglichkeit
beim Cloud Provider, die Logs der Applikation
Ja, das ist das, was ich dir
eigentlich gerade sagen wollte.
In Google Cloud kannst du
in den Log Explorer reingehen
und der Log Explorer, also bei Google Cloud
funktioniert das so.
Google hat
so ein paar Standardsachen in dem Cluster
vorinstalliert. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man das,
also du wirst das Ding ja wahrscheinlich per Terraform
oder irgendwie anders aufbauen,
ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man das überhaupt konfigurieren
kann. Google
hat dort einen Service
standardmäßig laufen in jedem
Node, der sich nennt
Ist es FluentD?
Ich bin mir
gerade aus dem Kopf gar nicht sicher.
Die haben so einen Managed
Service laufen in diesem, in
jedem Google Kubernetes Cluster,
der deine Applikationslogs einsammelt
und in den Google Log
Storage packt.
Und das ist das, was du, wenn du den Log Explorer
aufmachst, das sieht dann so
aus, hier guck. Und das schickt Google
automatisch weiter über diesen
Managed Service in deinem Cluster.
Kannst du dann auch drinnen suchen und sonst
was. Und das sind deine Anwendungslogs.
Du findest da drin auch Clusterlogs,
aber du findest auch den ganz normalen Log
Output von deinen
Containern. Ja, du findest den Cluster,
findest aber auch den Log Output von deinen
Containern drinnen.
Ein bescheides Beispiel finden.
Whatever.
Und darauf
kannst du Alerts setzen. Also wenn du
zum Beispiel eine Anwendung hast, die ab und zu
mal
Exceptions postet und bei einer ganz
speziellen Exception willst du eine E-Mail,
machst du
eine Alert-Regel auf diesen Filter
hier oben drinnen. Ja, du kannst das hier
filtern, hier sieht man es auch schön. Hier oben kannst
du ganz viele verschiedene Sachen eintragen,
nach was du filtern willst. Kannst du das sogar
nach Namespace, in dem dir der Workload
läuft, einschränken. Sogar,
ich glaube sogar nach Tags, nach
Annotations im Kubernetes kannst du das einschränken.
Und dann kannst du genau einstellen, was
du willst, dann machst du ein Alert drauf und gut ist.
Das ist die einfachste Variante, wenn man keinen
eigenen Monitoring-Krempel basteln möchte.
Sollte erwähnt, Google bietet
mittlerweile auch Managed Prometheus an
für ihr Kubernetes.
Die gefährlichsten Hacker
der Welt.
Eine Stunde vier.
Heute nicht.
Wir monitoren nicht ordentlich und machen
auch nichts mit den Daten.
Übrigens,
noch eine Sache dazu,
niemand monitort wirklich ordentlich.
In dem Sinne,
dass du sagen kannst, ja du kannst dich immer komplett
drauf verlassen oder es kommen keine sinnlosen
Meldungen. Also in meinem aktuellen Job ist es
auch so, das Monitoring ist eigentlich
insgesamt relativ gut eingestellt,
aber es gibt einen Service,
der hat jeden Tag
Monitoring-Meldungen und das sind total
unsinnige Warnings. Also der hat
keine Notifications und
es werden keine Alerts verschickt aufs Handy
oder sowas. Aber da hat jeden
Tag, wenn du in das Monitoring
System reinguckst, machst du das morgens
auf, guckst rein und siehst, aha
fünf Warnings von diesem
Service mal wieder.
Guckst rein, aha, ist der gleiche
Schwachsinn, der jeden Tag drinnen steht, kannst du einfach löschen.
Niemand monitort ordentlich.
Wir haben Private Cloud
Kubernetes.
Was würdest du da empfehlen, um Logs zu
durchsuchen? Aktuell werden die alle an der Liste. Ja, kann man machen.
Ich suche so etwas, wo ich Regeln
als Code definieren kann.
Ähm,
meinst du sowas in der Richtung hier?
Dass du hier so
Search-Queries reinschreibst?
Oder wie? Dass du hier Search-Queries
reinschreiben kannst? Also,
du kannst mal Promtail, also hier
Promtail,
das kannst du dir mal angucken.
Wenn ihr eh schon
Grafana und Prometheus verwendet.
Prometheus braucht
man dafür glaube ich gar nicht.
Aber dann kannst du Queries in
Grafana machen.
Das ist ganz nice. Falls du das
nicht schon kennst.
Getting started.
Haben die gescheite, haben die gescheit.
Ja. Brauch mal ein gescheites Bild.
Sorry.
Ja. Genau.
LogQL.
Ja.
Dann kannst du dann solche Abfragen hier machen. Willst du sowas
haben? Promtail und Loki.
Ja. Also Promtail
ist das Ding, was die Logs einsammelt.
Da gibt's, da gibt's aber noch mehr.
Es gibt
noch, äh, wie heißt das andere
Ding? Logstash gibt's glaube ich noch.
Was gibt's denn da alles?
Da gibt's jede Menge.
Fluentbit. Fluentbit ist das, was Google verwendet.
Fluentbit ist das, was Google verwendet
um, äh, die haben nen Managed Fluentbit
auf jedem Google
Kubernetes Node, auf jedem
GKE Node, der das an den
Google Log Storage schickt.
Craylog. Craylog. War das nicht
Logstash?
Oder bring ich das durcheinander?
Ach doch. Ach Logstash ist die Elastik
Geschichte. Deswegen denke ich gerade.
Fluentbit und FluentD
ist das gleiche, oder?
Ja, genau. Das finde ich nicht verkehrt.
Man muss ja auch
das Monitoring monitoren. Ja, irgendwann
beißt sich da die Katze in den Schwanz. Oder
sagt man die Schlange in den Schwanz? Die Katze in den Schwanz.
Ach ihr habt, ja genau.
Ihr habt's euch ja
schon angeguckt gerade im Chat.
Nutzt ihr beim Kubernetes Monitoring
in Checkmk auch den Agent von Checkmk?
Ja, aber das ist scheiße.
Ich mag das Checkmk Kubernetes
Monitoring überhaupt nicht.
Ich hab jetzt Managed
Kubernetes eingeschaltet
für unsere GKE Cluster.
Das Problem ist,
dass wir mittlerweile fast mehr
Management Pods am Laufen haben als
echten Workload in unserem Cluster.
Und dann hast du wiederum das Problem mit
Maximum Pods
pro Node
und IPs, die ausgehen, wenn du nicht
aufpasst. Also
Kubernetes ist echt
ein eigenes Ding für sich.
Der Eisenmann...
Der Eisen...
Der Eismann Bepo...
Ich hab der Eisenmann Pro gelesen
gerade. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ja, das ist
eigentlich ein Indikator dafür,
dass die grundsätzlichen Sachen,
wofür man Monitoring braucht, noch gar nicht
erfüllt sind. Ja, sich nämlich darüber
Gedanken zu machen, was für Services
hat man laufen
und welche Services davon sind
wie wichtig.
Das ist die Grundvoraussetzung dafür,
damit man Sachen ordentlich monitoren kann.
Damit man auch überhaupt erstmal die Tools
auswählen kann, damit man auch erstmal Regeln
definieren kann, damit man sich Notification
Channels
überlegen kann. Die Grundvoraussetzung
dafür, dass du das überhaupt gescheit machen kannst, ist,
du musst dir erstmal... erster Schritt ist,
was für Services hab ich eigentlich?
Weil wenn du das nicht weißt, kannst du dir
Monitoring komplett schenken.
Was für Services hab ich eigentlich?
So. Oder...
Oder zumindest mal, wenn es
nicht auf Service-Ebene ist, mal zumindest
okay, welche Kisten
hab ich laufen? Du brauchst so eine
Übersicht, was hast du eigentlich?
So. Und wenn du das hast, ist der nächste Schritt
zu überlegen, okay, wie wichtig ist
denn was? Weil es kann ja
durchaus sein, dass du, sagen wir mal, fünf Services
hast, aber
der eine bringt halt ultra viel
Geld und kostet dich auch
mega viel Geld, wenn der ausfällt.
Und die anderen vier sind eher so nice to have
für irgendwelche internen Tools oder so.
Natürlich ist das sinnvoll,
wenn man das für alle Services einrichtet.
Es ist sicherlich auch sinnvoll, wenn man
für alle Services Alert setzt.
Was allerdings nicht sinnvoll ist, ist
für irgendwie...
Service, den zwei Leute benutzen und das auch nur
intern, nachts um
drei irgendjemanden aufzuwecken.
Bei einem Service, der dich
ein paar Millionen kostet, wenn er ausfällt,
dann solltest du vielleicht nachts um drei doch
lieber die Leute aufwecken, dass das morgens um sieben wieder läuft.
Mache eigentlich nur
Async-Monitoring.
Also Monitoring ist ja
per Definition asynchron.
Was verstehst
du unter Async-Monitoring?
Mein synchrones Monitoring
heißt, würde ja heißen,
dein Service hat irgendeinen
Neuro-Link in deinem Hirn
und sobald
irgendwas ist, kriegst du es quasi
im gleichen CPU-Cycle
mit, wie deine Anwendung Probleme hat.
Monitoring ist ja per
Definition irgendwie asynchron, oder?
Mal kurz mal in das
Tastatur rausziehen, wieder reinstecken.
Mein RGB spackt gerade rum.
Zwei Tage später draufschauen.
Ja, dann scheinen sie nicht so wichtig
zu sein.
Finde ich auch nicht verkehrt, sich
alle paar Tage mal so ein bisschen
die Metriken anzugucken, die einen interessieren.
Am Wochenende war bei unserem
RZ-Anbieter Wartung am
Stromfeed A.
Ich ging am Freitag dahin, um
kleine Geräte auf Feed B zu verbinden.
Was passiert? Alles ging offline.
Hat sich herausgestellt, dass beim Raum die Stromlasten falsch
angeschrieben wurden.
Oh, ja, ZG, das ist schlecht.
Aber warum?
Wo ist das Problem? Aktuell waren doch noch beide unter Strom, oder?
Ach nee, als sie die
Wartung gemacht haben, ging dann alles off.
Nicht als du im RZ warst.
Ja, gut, das ist ja easy.
Da trifft dich ja keine Schuld.
Du hast das ordnungsgemäß ausgeführt.
Du bist kein Elektriker, der
mal kurz die Verkabelung vor dem Vorfeld
überprüfen muss. Geschweige denn, dass du
da gar nicht dran kommst.
Und nicht darfst.
Also für wichtige Sachen
willst du Notifications haben.
Und trotzdem jeden Tag reingucken.
Man muss sagen,
so blöd es jetzt klingt,
wenn man eine große
Anzahl von Services hat und darunter
liegen eine große Anzahl von Systemen,
je länger man
die Systeme hat und je besser
man die Systeme kennt,
umso besser erkennst du Probleme
anhand von
irgendwelchen Graphen
und von irgendwelchen
Verhaltensauffälligkeiten.
Das ist schwierig
zu sagen immer
ja, genau ab dem Punkt ist der
Schwellwert erreicht und sowas.
Manchmal guckst du dir einfach auch 30 Tage
Verlauf an von
Connections oder
von RAM-Auslastungen zu Usern
zu sonst was und denkst dir, wenn du dir das anguckst,
sag mal, hat das vor einem halben Jahr nicht noch
anders ausgesehen?
Dann gehst du mal ein bisschen zurück und guckst rein
und dann stellst du fest, hä?
Guck mal hier irgendwie, ab dem
dem und dem Datum
ist das auf einmal ganz merkwürdig.
Da braucht der
Verbindungsaufbau jetzt irgendwie 16
Millisekunden statt 2 und dann stellst
du fest, ach guck mal da, da gab's ja
einen Release am Wochenende vorher, neue Softwareversion
und so haben wir
auch schon die ein oder anderen Bugs in Anwendungen
gefunden. Irgendwie sieht das
merkwürdig aus. Und dieses, dass das
irgendwie merkwürdig aussieht, kriegst
du oftmals nur dadurch raus, dass
du die Systeme kennst mit der Zeit.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, man muss trotzdem nicht
jeden Schrott monitoren.
Nur das, was einen interessiert.
Also ich muss nicht monitoren,
also weiß ich,
wie viele
Filehandles irgendein
User offen hat oder sowas.
Einfach nur just for fun auf
jedem System. Ja,
natürlich, das kann mal Probleme machen, wenn
die Filehandles ausgehen.
Aber das ist nix, was man,
ja keine Ahnung, das ist nix, was man
im Vorfeld
irgendwie ausschließen will.
Oder,
also ich würde nicht alles
an Filehandles monitoren.
Dann art es total aus, weil du dann irgendwann
sagst, hey guck mal, dann musst
du auch das, das, das und das und auf einmal
hast du halt wieder terabyteweise irgendwelche Metriken,
die sich keiner anguckt.
Wenn du jetzt irgendwie ein Problem hattest,
ja, weil mal die Filehandles ausgegangen
sind und du sagst, ey ich will das aber überwachen,
dass das nicht wieder passiert. Ja, vollkommen in Ordnung.
Aber ich finde einfach nur
sinnlos einsammeln
bringt nix. Es gibt ein paar Sachen, die man
sich immer wieder anguckt,
aber es gibt so viele unsinnigen Metriks.
Mir fällt jetzt leider aus dem Stehgreif
gar nicht so viele gute Beispiele
dazu ein.
Ich müsste jetzt einfach mal irgendwie den Standard
hier, weil wir hatten doch gerade den Node.
GitHub Node Exporter
Prometheus.
Gucken wir mal, das explodiert ja gefühlt
auch gerade in die Welt von einem Linux System.
So, was hast du hier?
ETH Tool.
Brauchst du
wirklich Netzwerk-Statistiken?
Ja, brauchst du, wird jetzt
einer sagen, weil ich will wissen,
Errors, Packet-Loss,
sonst was. Mir persönlich
reicht eigentlich
die Bandbreite.
Dass man mal irgendwelche
Peaks sieht. Disk-Stats, gibt's
auch tausende Sachen, die dich nicht interessieren.
ARP.
Who the fuck cares, irgendwelche ARP-Einträge
auf Linux, ja?
Kannst du den nicht im Einzelfall dazuschalten?
Ne, das ist tatsächlich nicht so einfach.
Wenn du die Sachen von einem System
einsammelst, per sagen wir hier Prometheus
Node Exporter, dann musst du den erst dann
umkonfigurieren und neu starten.
Bei Prometheus ist das übrigens alles
halb so wild. Prometheus macht enorm
viele Metriken pro Sekunde.
Also das bringst du kaum in die Knie.
Aber ich find's trotzdem immer
Verschwendung und unsinnig, so ultra viel
einzusammeln und davon nur 5% zu benutzen.
Contract!
Juckt auch niemand! Guckste
nie rein! Wobei,
guckste nie rein, stimmt nicht. Ich hab mir tatsächlich
schon aktive TCP-Verbindungen angeguckt.
CPU Frequency
Interessiert dich null!
Juck dich null!
Idle Descriptor, guck keine Sau rein!
Pressure!
Was?
SE-Linux-Statistik!
Guck mal, es wird wirklich Gott um die Welt
exportiert, wenn man sich das hier anguckt.
Und da kommt ja noch alles Custommäßige
dazu.
Das Wichtigste ist, dass man sich überlegt, was
wie wichtig ist und wofür
man Notifications haben will.
Was hältst du von
Azure Arc?
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt gar keine Ahnung, was Azure Arc ist.
CPU-Last ist interessant.
Es gibt so ein paar Basic-Metriken, die würde ich
tatsächlich von jedem Server sammeln.
CPU-Last, RAM-Auslastung,
Disk-Usage und sowas, das würde ich tatsächlich
machen. Ja, ob ich
die Kernel Entropy
Informations brauche in meinem
Prometheus, weiß ich nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, was Azure Arc ist.
Stale NFS
File Handles? Klingt ein bisschen
so, oder? Hast du mal einen
Remount probiert?
Hast du mal einen Remount probiert?
Ansonsten ist NFS eklig.
Du kannst auch Force unmounten, aber das mag
NFS oftmals nicht. Haben wir jetzt eigentlich
Updates? Ja, ich habe Updates gemacht.
Und eins noch
zum Schluss, um die Monitoring-Sache
abzuschließen. Es ist immer wieder individuell.
Also das, was ich jetzt hier gesagt habe
und meinen Eindruck
widerspiegelt, kann komplett falsch sein
für euch. Weil die grundsätzlichen Sachen
mit sich erstmal darüber klar werden, welche
man hat, welche wichtig sind, das nicht.
Aber wenn es in eurem Anwendungsfall
Sinn macht, dann monitort mehr.
Es hat ja
keinen Sinn, nur weil irgendwie der random Dude auf Twitch
das jetzt sagt. Wenn ihr denkt,
das ist sinnvoll, dann macht das. Das kommt immer auf
die Umgebung an, was für Leute
man da sitzt an, was für Services man laufen hat,
wie sich die Infrastruktur zusammensetzt.
Da gibt es keinen Pass für alles.
Ich meine, es gibt Leute,
die haben nur Windows Server.
Die müssen ja auch irgendwie überwacht werden.
Stellt euch mal vor,
und dann gibt es ganz verrückte
Leute, die haben da auch noch
PRTG und machen damit dann
Linux-Überwachung und sowas.
Cringe.
Dann ist ja gut.
Der Wublos
ist ja ein bekannter
C++-Fan.
Wie wir alle wissen.
Was haben wir denn eigentlich
so am Start?
Was ist das denn?
40 Dinge, die er
realisiert hat auf
der Internetseite.
Ich...
Wisst ihr, wann ich 40 werde?
Dauert nicht mal lang.
Ich werde dieses Jahr 40.
Das ist Extremely Monarch S.
Dieses Jahr, ja.
Massive Monarch S
ist das.
Ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen,
dass ich schon so alt bin.
Wir machen keinen Geburtstags-Stream,
weil ich sage nicht, wann ich Geburtstag habe.
Aber wir machen
eine Idee darum.
Vielleicht Geburtstags-Stream.
Mal gucken.
Ich weiß bloß nicht, was soll ich da überhaupt machen?
Ihr könnt mir ja alle Primes
haben dann.
Easy.
Ich auch nicht.
Ich meine, Chat.
Wie viele...
Jungs, am Ohr.
Kurz mein Netzteil richtig aufsetzen.
Wie viele fast 40-jährige
Leute kennt ihr?
Die auf Twitch streamen
und laufen irgendwie so was
wie MonkaS von sich geben, Mann.
Oder die vor dem Spiegel stehen
und sagen keckeln.
Das ist so...
Einen, ja.
Ja.
Ja, ja.
Das kommt aber auch oftmals nur so vor, gell.
Das ist so...
Einen.
Ja.
Ja, ja.
Das kommt aber auch oftmals nur so vor.
Ich meine, wenn man klein ist,
kommen einem Leute mit 20 übelst alt
vor und
die Eltern, die dann irgendwie noch
älter sind, teilweise denkst du sonst was,
wie alt die sind, ja.
Man selbst sieht das immer anders.
Pepega sage ich auch
manchmal.
Das, was ganz schön pock ist, aber auch.
Das checken die meisten nicht, aber
ein paar kapieren's.
Postchamp.
Postchamp sage ich auch.
Aber nicht...
Aber eigentlich selten auf der Arbeit.
Postchamp ist eigentlich eines meiner Lieblings-
Lieblings-Emo's.
So nach dem Motto, und, geht's jetzt?
Postchamp? Postchamp?
Nein, funktioniert nicht.
Schlimm.
Sag mal Leute, verwendet irgendjemand
von euch einen...
Wie nennt man das
gescheit?
Äh, einen Discord
Mods?
Also ich meine, keine Mods
auf Discord, sondern Discord
Modifications.
Sowas wie zum Beispiel
Vencord oder sowas.
Weil das ist ja der cutest Discord
Client.
Warum auch immer.
Verwendet jemand sowas, oder gibt's auch hier
Better Discord, gibt's da auch noch?
Verwendet er sowas?
Weil, das Ding ist folgendes.
Ich hab mal eine Frage an
die Kenner unter euch.
Ich find das,
ich find das ja vom Ansatz her sehr nice,
Plugins und sowas.
Ich hab mal eine Frage, eine Frage an euch.
Nein, nein, nein, es geht jetzt nix on.
Ich hab mal eine Frage an euch.
An die ganzen Discord Checker.
Gibt es in Discord eine Möglichkeit,
alle Leute in einem Channel
zu muten?
Wenn es nicht mein Channel ist.
Nein, die Antwort ist, das geht nicht.
Ich weiß, dass das mit offiziellen Mitteln nicht geht.
Aber kennt ihr
eine Discord Modification
oder ein Plugin, was das kann?
Weil, jetzt mal ein Beispiel.
Ich weiß übrigens nicht, warum Discord
das nicht kann.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr spielt MMOs
und ihr seid in irgendeinem Raid dabei.
Ja, das bringt ja nix.
Pass mal auf, ich bin doch noch nicht fertig.
Ich bin
noch nicht fertig.
Stellt euch mal vor,
ihr spielt ein MMO und ihr geht in irgendein
was weiß ich,
nehmen wir mal ein 40 Mann Raid,
wie das früher in World of Warcraft war.
Ihr geht in einen 40 Mann Raid,
in dem Channel sind alle wild am durcheinander schwätzen
und einer ist halt der Anführer,
der sagt, wo es lang geht.
Ihr wollt alle muten und danach
den Leader wieder entmuten.
Das war früher
zu Urzeiten und so eigentlich gar
kein Problem, noch mit TeamSpeak 2
und haste nicht gesehen, aber
in Discord geht das nicht.
In Discord geht das nur,
wenn du der Channel Owner
bist und das machst.
Aber vielleicht will ja der Channel Owner,
dass jeder was sagen kann,
aber ich will nur den einen hören.
Die einzige Möglichkeit,
die ich da bis jetzt gefunden habe ist,
alle Leute von Hand anzuklicken
und zu muten, was aber nicht
funktioniert, sobald ein neuer reinkommt.
Hintergrund ist folgender,
sag mal,
Chat,
bin ich jetzt
einfach nur blind, oder?
Ist
der
Nexonus Name kleiner als
Cursed Kiddo?
Warum ist dein Name kleiner
als sein Name?
Oder ist das einfach nur die
Groß- und Kleinschreibung?
Ich glaub, das ist einfach nur die Groß- und Kleinschreibung.
Wenn man mal die Os miteinander
comparet, dann sind die gleich groß.
Ich glaub, das sieht einfach nur so aus.
Kannst selbst ein Plugin schreiben,
da brauchst du aber
ne Discord Modification dafür.
Ich will das eigentlich
gar nicht selbst machen.
Ich mein, ich kann
ich kann doch nicht
ich kann doch nicht der Einzige sein,
der
sowas haben will, oder?
Discord Mute All. Also, der Hintergrund
ist folgender. Ich sag euch jetzt mal, worum
es genau geht.
Ich hab übrigens schon was heute gefunden hier.
GitHub Discord
Java API
gibt es sogar. Hier.
Java Rapper
für Discord.
Da drüber hab ich auch schon geguckt, ob das möglich
ist, aber nein, das ist nicht möglich.
Gab sogar ne Stack Overflow
Frage zu.
Dann hätt ich mal sogar was in Java programmiert.
Oder in Java, wie das
die coolen Leute sagen. Also,
Discord Bot, nee.
Discord Bot müsste ja der
Channel, beziehungsweise der
Server Owner für den Channel
machen. Ich bin ja einfach nur ein
Typ, der in den Channel reinjoint,
und ich will nur für mich alle muten.
Ich will nicht alle muten, die wirklich
in dem Channel drin sind. Ich will die nur für mich stumm
schalten. Und dass ich nur den Leader
höre. Ja, aber das
scheint es nicht zu geben.
Also, der Hintergrund ist folgender.
Ich spiele ja öfters MMO,
PvP in einem MMO.
Also, ich spiele immer noch Dark Age
of Camelot seit über 20 Jahren
auf nem Freeshot.
Und was wir gerne hätten, ist, wir spielen meistens
mit mehr oder weniger den gleichen Leuten.
Bisschen random Leute
sind immer dabei. Je nachdem, falls mal
einer nicht da ist. Aber wir spielen zum größten Teil
immer mit gleichen, beziehungsweise
ähnlicher Pool an Leuten.
So. Und
was echt gut funktioniert ist,
wenn man nicht
mitrennt,
Kreiselgrind, genau.
Wenn man nicht mitrennt im Zerg,
beziehungsweise, ich hab das
ja schon mal gestreamt,
also,
da spielen ja ganz viele Leute sinnloses
100 gegen 100
und wir rennen uns die Köppe ein.
Das ist nice, das macht auch teilweise Spaß,
aber, was ich viel nicer finde,
ist, oder was wir viel nicer finden,
ist, eben mit ner Gruppe rumzulaufen,
so, sagen wir mal,
in der Nähe von der
Main Battle Group,
uns drum herum die Leute abzufarmen.
Ja, vielleicht auch mal ein paar nicer Fights
zwischen Gruppen, vielleicht auch mal
die ein oder anderen Nachzügler abfarmen,
einfach, einfach was machen für uns,
aber so in der Nähe von der Battle Group,
der eben Action ist.
So, für alles andere
ist es kein Problem, ja.
Wenn man irgendwelche PvP Events macht,
sonst wie was, da geht man in Discord,
8 Mann in den Channel, gut ist.
Überhaupt kein Problem. Wenn man allerdings
um die Battle Group spielen will,
dann
will ich mit meinen 8 Leuten
im Discord sein,
aber, ich möchte den
Battle Group Leader hören,
der in nem ganz anderen Channel ist,
aber niemand, der in dem Channel
drin ist, noch außer ihm.
Nur ihn.
Oder sie. Ab und zu haben wir tatsächlich
auch weibliche BG Leader.
Ich will nur,
ich will nur den Leader hören.
Und das funzt mit Discord einfach nicht.
Und das nervt mich.
Es ist ja mit Discord schon gar nicht so einfach,
in zwei verschiedenen Channels gleichzeitig zu sein.
Das einzige, was ich bisher rausgefunden habe,
wie man das machen kann, ist, ich starte einmal
Discord im Browser und einmal den normalen Client
und joine dann in unterschiedliche Channels,
also, ich will den
Battle Group Leader hören und im Zweifelsfall
vielleicht dem auch was sagen können,
mal schnell,
aber ich will niemand
anderes hören und ansonsten nur mit
meinen 8 Leuten im anderen Channel sein.
Das geht halt net.
Das ist halt richtig kacke,
dass das net funktioniert.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
warum das in Discord nicht geht.
Discord ist doch mit entstanden, so als
quasi, ja,
als Voice Social Gaming
Plattform.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das umschreiben kann.
Und dass solche Dinger da nicht drinne gehen, versteh ich nicht.
Also, vielleicht kennt ja irgendjemand
von euch da ne Möglichkeit,
Discord Mute All
in nem Channel zu machen.
Und sei es auch nur
mit irgendeinem Plugin für Better Discord
oder sowas.
Es ist kein Voice Call.
Es ist ein Discord Server
mit Voice Channel.
Das ist mein Discord Server.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Es sei denn, dass es kleinseitig ist Mute,
wie wenn du die Leute anklickst und stummschaltest.
Doch.
Das eine ist komplett Mute für alle
und das andere ist nur für dich gemutet.
Und Member
klingt schon stark nach, als ich muss
Channel Admin sein oder Server
oder Serverbesitzer.
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Das macht berechtigungstechnisch im Discord sicherlich nen Unterschied.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht geht's.
Ich kacke, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Oh, der Chat gekackt gerade ab.
Das, genau.
Das versteh ich gar nicht.
Warum geht das in TS?
Gibt es eigentlich irgendjemanden, der TeamSpeak 5 wirklich verwendet?
Ich kenne niemand.
Alle, die TeamSpeak verwenden, verwenden noch
uraltes TeamSpeak.
Teilweise noch TeamSpeak 2.
Ich war letztes Jahr
Dieses Jahr nicht mehr.
Aber letztes Jahr
war ich
für irgendein Game.
Ich glaube für Warzone.
Ne, das war schon vor 2 Jahren oder so.
Als ich noch ein bisschen Warzone gespielt habe,
war ich manchmal
mit anderen Leuten zusammen
im Voice chatten.
Das war TeamSpeak 2 noch.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
Ja, es gibt TeamSpeak 5.
Das sieht jetzt aus wie ein Discord-Klon.
Sieht auch sehr nach Javascript aus.
Und...
Echt nicht Discord-Klon.
Guckst du mit Chat und allem.
Braucht man nicht
einen Account mittlerweile,
wenn du TeamSpeak, den offiziellen Server, joinen willst?
Schon, ja.
Oder ich weiß es nicht.
Also wenn du einen privaten Server hast, was geht,
bis glaube ich 32 Leute, musst du nicht mal Lizenzkosten
für bezahlen, kann man sich immer noch TeamSpeak Server installieren.
TeamSpeak 5
ist glaube ich nur der Client.
Wie der Server aussieht, weiß ich nicht.
Ob es einen extra TeamSpeak 5 Server gibt.
Ich weiß es nicht. Habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Das findest nicht nur du.
Das macht es auch.
Je nach Qualitätssettings und Status von deinem
Discord-Server, mal mehr oder weniger.
Ja, TS hört sich besser an.
Und TS hat auch,
und das auch mal mehr oder weniger,
weniger Lackency.
Das ist so.
Das empfindest nicht nur du.
Ich glaube, die sagen am Anfang
auch hier Login, aber das kannst du einfach überspringen.
So, machen wir den Kram mal wieder zu.
So...
Komm, wir gucken uns auch irgendwas aus.
Wir haben noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit.
Was haben wir denn noch?
Okay, 40 Dinge,
die ich erst nach 40
gemerkt habe.
Okay, pass mal auf.
Wir machen jetzt Fifat.
Wir gucken uns einfach die Kapitel an,
ohne das Video anzugucken.
Wir sparen uns jetzt einfach 15 Minuten.
Okay?
Also,
was hat er gelernt?
Was hat er gelernt?
Okay.
Was kommt auf die Gesundheit an?
Ja, okay, da gebe ich ihm recht.
Ordentlich pennen ist gesund.
Ja, das stimmt auch.
Und so wie ich es mache, ist falsch,
mit einem Handy im Bett einzupennen,
mit irgendwelchem Schwachsinn streamen,
wo du sinnloses Zeug träumst,
weil ein dummer Stream im Hintergrund läuft.
Ja.
Wasser ist der beste Trink auf der Welt.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Ja, Wasser. Ich trinke auch nur Wasser.
Also, naja, sagen wir mal so.
Die Ruhe ist jetzt übertrieben.
Wenn ich irgendwo beispielsweise am Mittagessen gehe,
dann gibt es da oftmals
nur mini Wasser und das lohnt sich.
Also, ich trinke zu 99%
und daheim ausschließlich Wasser.
Jetzt auch gerade.
Und das, obwohl mich keiner ans Trinken erinnert hat.
Wasser, beste.
Sprudelwasser
oder stilles Wasser?
Was sagt ihr?
Still?
Sprudel?
Ich trinke beides.
Ich wechsle da tatsächlich dazwischen.
Ich trinke sowohl stilles Wasser
als auch Sprudelwasser.
Ich finde, Sprudelwasser ist erfrischender
und
löscht den Durst
irgendwie besser.
Aber wenn du
den ganzen Tag
nebenbei was trinkst, bevorzuge ich stilles Wasser.
Ja.
Man sollte öfters Nein sagen.
Okay.
Da habe ich kein Problem mit.
Was notwendig ist.
Man soll höflich sein.
Gut, da weiß ich nicht,
was er bei dem Punkt sagt.
Also, es zahlt sich
auf jeden Fall aus, nicht der allergrößte
Spaß zu sein, gegenüber anderen
Leuten. Wobei es sicherlich genug Leute
geben wird, die behaupten werden,
genau das Gegenteil zahlt sich aus.
Jaja.
Nachdem ich eh alle anderen Menschen nicht mag,
beschränkt sich meine Interaktion
eh auf ein Minimum.
Es gibt, es gibt
nichts wie zu spät.
Ne, wie kann man das gescheit übersetzen?
Es ist nie zu spät, könnte man das wahrscheinlich
am besten übersetzen.
Ja, dazu habe ich ja auch letztens
ein Video gemacht. Der Sache stimme ich zu.
Discomfort
is growth. Okay, ja.
Der Sache würde ich auch zustimmen.
Ich hätte auch nicht gedacht,
als ich angefangen habe
zu rennen, dass ich mal über 10
Kilometer am Stück packe, ohne danach
dead get zu sein.
Power is super power.
Ich glaube, der meint nicht damit,
was ich als erstes im Kopf hatte.
Weiß ich nicht, was er dazu sagt.
Man sollte sich nicht selbst
unterschätzen. Ja, okay.
Äh.
Sponsoring?
Wahrscheinlich auch Sponsoring.
Ich bin dumm und das ist
okay. Ja, man muss nicht alles wissen.
Das stimmt. Es ist egal, was
andere Menschen oder andere Leute von einem
denken. Ja, so wirklich
egal ist es einem eigentlich nie.
Aber ich habe das ja auch schon mal in einem Video gesagt.
Es gibt
ganz viele solcher
Coaching-Videos, so
nach dem Motto, ja scheiß drauf, was andere Leute
sagen. Da
fehlt eine ganz wichtige Voraussetzung
für. Damit es einem
egal sein kann, beziehungsweise eigentlich
geht es ja gar nicht ums egal
sein, sondern um sich das nicht so
sehr zu Herzen zu nehmen.
Ja. Ob es jetzt einem wirklich
komplett egal sein soll, was
irgendwelche Leute erzählen
oder überein, weiß ich nicht.
Aber man sollte sich das nicht so zu Herzen nehmen.
Die Grundvoraussetzung dafür ist
allerdings nicht, dass ich mir irgendein Coaching-Video
angucke, wo mir einer sagt, ja scheiß drauf,
was andere von dir denken, Alter.
Ne, das funktioniert nicht.
Damit das funktioniert,
dass man sich die Sachen, die
andere überein sagen, nicht mehr so zu Herzen
nimmt, ist, dass man mit sich
selbst irgendwie so,
wie nennt man das,
im Reinen ist das
falsche Wort, ja, dass man mit sich selbst
halbwegs zufrieden ist, ja.
Dass man auch mal
in sich gegangen ist,
dass man auch mal weiß,
was man nicht kann, was man gut
kann, dass einen
andere Leute eben nicht so
einfach kränken können mit irgendwas,
weil man eben die Wahrheit nicht hören kann
oder so, ja.
Oder sich überall darüber aufregt.
Also man muss halbwegs mit sich irgendwie
mal zufrieden sein, erst
dann wird es einem wirklich egal sein.
Was andere Leute überein
denken, beziehungsweise dann nimmt man sich
auch nicht mal so zu Herzen.
Weil wenn man permanente Selbstzweifel hat,
dann wird das nix.
Okay, nicht versuchen Leute zu
beeindrucken,
sondern Value adden, das klingt nach
diagonal skalieren.
Blaming is stupid.
Kommt drauf an, wenn man Recht hat, nicht.
No one is coming to save me.
Okay. Oh.
Ja, das fällt bei mir eh flach.
Stop looking at the rearview mirror.
Ja, das glaube ich, das machen
auch viele Leute nicht.
Also, ich gehe davon aus, dass er nicht wirklich
ins Auto gucken, in den Rückspiegel
gucken meint. Ich gehe davon aus, dass er meint,
es hat keinen Sinn immer wieder zu sagen,
ey, hätte
ich das und das mal anders gemacht, ja.
Habe ich auch letztens ein Video dazu gemacht.
An Weihnachten.
Boah, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Äh, kein Bock jetzt.
Ich glaube viele Leute realisieren
zu ähnlichen Zeiten ähnliche Sachen.
Für manches, für manches
muss man einfach ein bisschen älter sein.
Und umgedreht, umgedreht
ist es auch so, manche Sachen, die man
mega nice fand, während man jung war
findet man das nicht so gut und
umgedreht findet man Sachen
gut, die man früher scheiße fand.
Ich glaube so geht es jedem.
Ja, du hast Recht, aber du hast noch nie
irgendwelche Competitive Multiplayer
Spiele gespielt, oder?
Das erste, was passiert
ist,
meine Teammates sind scheiße, Mann.
Why you play like shit?
Das ist normal.
Die sind alle am Rumpflame immer.
Und in MOBAs ganz besonders
schlimm. Deswegen spiele ich auch keine
MOBAs.
Ja,
Business Context, gebe ich dir Recht.
Aber selbst da hast du Leute, die sind einfach nur
nervig und manchmal
musst du dann auch mal was sagen.
Manchmal musst du es auch echt ansprechen.
Wenn die Leute immer scheiße bauen.
Der Neo-Wim-Stream,
den muss ich noch machen.
Quality is Destiny.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es dieses Video gibt auf Youtube.
Es gibt so einen...
Moment.
You play
like shit.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das Video gibt.
Nee.
Ach shit, ich finde es jetzt nicht.
Es gibt so einen, wie gesagt,
ich spiele ein 20 Jahre altes MMO
und einer
der Battle-Group-Leader
ist ein Deutscher.
Und da gibt es so einen Voice-Clip von dem,
wo er ganz laut rumschreit
You play like shit.
Aber übelst am ausrasten ist.
Gibt es leider nicht auf Youtube.
Also wo wir gerade dabei sind,
dass man andere Leute nicht flamen soll.
In Multiplayer-Spielen wird
immer rum geflamed. Das geht, glaube ich, nicht anders.
Wobei, also,
das würde schon anders gehen.
Aber die Natur der Sache
im Team-Multiplayer-Spielen
ist einfach,
dass die Leute gerne
Teammates flamen.
Es ist ja auch einfach, Teammates zu flamen
und nicht nur im Multiplayer-Spiel oder allgemein,
weil dann muss man sich nicht selbst
darüber Gedanken machen, dass man es vielleicht verkackt hat.
Hey, es gibt in Spielen
immer wieder die Situation,
dass es kacke ist,
was deine Teammates machen.
Aber manchmal, und das trifft bei Multiplayer-Spielen öfters zu,
als einem lieb ist,
manchmal ist es wichtig,
die Teammates besser zu machen
in einem Multiplayer-Spiel,
anstatt alleine das Richtige.
Wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr spielt jetzt irgendeinen
oder keiner,
stellt euch vor, ihr spielt irgendeinen Shooter
oder irgendeinen Strategiespieler, ist egal.
Und irgendeiner sagt, so Leute, wir gehen jetzt da hin.
Es ist die bescheuertste Idee ever
aus eurer Sicht, dort jetzt hinzugehen.
Und
was passiert ist,
ihr geht an den Spot,
wo vielleicht game-theorie-technisch
der bessere wäre, aber alleine,
und die anderen vier gehen auf den schlechten Spot
und verrecken dort
vier gegen fünf.
Dann wäre es wahrscheinlich besser gewesen,
ihr hättet gesagt, scheiß drauf,
es ist zwar dumm, aber ich gehe mit.
Also gerade in Multiplayer-Spielen ist es manchmal sinnvoll,
zusammen das Falsche
zu machen.
Und wahrscheinlich kann man das auch
auf noch ganz viele andere Situationen übertragen.
Was ist das denn?
Wie Android und IOS
das Windows Phone zerstörten.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob die das zerstören mussten.
Ich habe irgendwie den Eindruck gehabt,
Microsoft hat da selbst dafür gesorgt,
dass ChiroPraktiker effektiv...
What the fuck?
Da krieg ich immer Videos empfoh...
Wow.
Da krieg ich immer Videos von empfohlen,
in Shorts,
auf meinem Handy,
wenn ich abends
das Handy aufmache,
da krieg ich immer Shorts empfohlen auf YouTube
von irgendwelchen Leuten,
die anderen Leuten so
Gelenke knacken und so.
So ganz merkwürdiger Content.
Und habt ihr auch manchmal das Problem,
dass die YouTube-App
auf eurem Handy automatisch beim Öffnen
einen Short startet, obwohl ihr gar
keinen Short gucken wollt.
Ihr macht die Handy-App auf und auf einmal startet ein Short.
Ich denk mir dann immer,
ich bin mit dem Finger irgendwo draufgekommen,
aber ich glaube,
das ist die Innen-Funktionalität von YouTube.
YouTube denkt jetzt,
du musst dir einen Short angucken.
Ich hab kein Android.
Warum Software-Entwickler immer schuld sind,
weil Manager-Leute nicht checken,
was sie machen.
Und es einfach ist, Entwickler zu blamen.
Oder generell
Technik-Leute zu blamen.
Anstatt beschissene Planung.
Was ist das?
List of the disastrous
US-Measure-System.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ja, gut.
Die sind wirklich...
Ist da BTU drinne?
Wo ist BTU drinne?
BTU ist die sinnloseste Einheit ever, Mann.
Chatge, ihr wisst natürlich alle,
was BTU ist.
Oder noch besser, BTU pro Stunde.
Auch eine ganz tolle Einheit.
...
bei usf wird die benutzt also wenn ihr eine usv kauft ist es nicht unwahrscheinlich dass
dort was von btu draufsteht sebi der flanke für den sub klimaanlagen ja die man lagen auch was
sagt er denn zu btu ja genau was
okay was was sagt was sagt diese tierliste
horsepower horsepower geht noch klar wie fahren hat mal das hat ja nichts mit unserer tonne zu
tun nehme ich mir an in akka was ist das hektar nee akka inches of water inches of mercury was
uns ja uns das macht mich auch immer durcheinander uns das macht mich auch immer durcheinander gerade
wenn du bei amazon
guckst und guckst logitech maus fünf ounces fluid ounce yard. yard ist auch so kohäuser ding man
ich schaue nicht das video zehn minuten um zu seiner liste zu kommen die gelden gelden ist auch
so kapp ja das ist schon ziemlich erschrocken aber die armee stehen darauf ge Julia time erklärt alles
eine sache die mich immer irritiert ist wenn leute
kilowattstunde als schreiben weil es wahrscheinlich von kennen es sieht
ähnlich aus ist aber komplett falsch weil das ist nicht durch die legt
durch die strecke so oder durch die zeit sondern es ist mal zeit ja es ist
kinderzeit ist auch ein bisschen doof erkennt man beim aussprechen nicht ist
aber komplett falsch irgendwie sagen youtube videos gar nicht zu wie kriegen
immer noch super krasse musik empfohlen weil ich einmal was abgespielt habe
musik am start offizieller mod support vorbei los geht drei
ja die machen schon einiges richtig mit dem game das ist genau das was das game
langfristig noch am leben hält das hat einen riesen hype gehabt und auch immer
noch so viel content dazu produziert wird wird aber früher oder später halt
einschlafen aber mit mod support können erst mit
offiziellen mod support können wir jetzt nicht mehr so viel content dazu
machen würde weil es erst mal bei der ersten partie gespielt hat von der
offiziellen mod support könnte ich mir echt vorstellen dass da einiges
einiges wobei hat das nicht schon seit anfang an offiziellen mod support gehabt
oder war das so ein halb offizielles ding so nach dem motto ja wir versuchen
das möglichst table zu halten können aber nichts versprechen oder so das
quadruple a game genau das ist auch wieder so ein market also sobald der typ
game weißt du wusstest du doch sofort das bullshit erzählt wird achtung
sicherheitswarnung tas motor warum es ist halt hier ein dummer wirklich ein
dummer kleiner konfigurationsfehler unterlaufen
da plötzlich da ist nix zumal die erstmals wlan rein kommen müssen
warum kriege ich so viel shit empfohlen kein passwort gesetzt ja aber selbst
wenn macht ja auch nichts also vielleicht nicht die nicht das
sinnvollste aber macht ja auch nichts das ding hängt ja im wlan da muss erst
mal einer in einem wlan sein dass er darauf zugreifen kann
also insofern verstehe ich nicht was sind das für shorts youtube meint das
will ich mir angucken man muss aber dazu sagen youtube hat
meine watch history verloren vor einer woche und wir haben kaum videos bisher
auf gehabt deswegen weiß youtube
nicht so genau was wir uns eigentlich angucken wollen
battlefront classic ist inzwischen über 20 jahre alt
viele gute spiele sind mittlerweile über 20 jahre alt kann man sich gar nicht
vorstellen und wisst ihr das ist eines der sachen woran ich wirklich merke dass
ich alt bin auch wenn es mir wirklich nicht so lange her vorkommt ich kann
mich daran erinnern wo ich das erste mal half-life gespielt habe 1998 1999 rum und das ist
1998 1999 rum und das ist
und das ist
25 jahre her kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen
ich komme das wirklich nicht so lange vor es ist ein vierteljahrhundert ist das
her wo ich half-life gespielt habe das erste mal cs 15 gab es damals noch nicht
ich kann mich noch daran erinnern als cs 0 version hatte cs 0 52 als noch nicht
mal ein automatisch wie nennt sich das so dynamisches fadenkreuz gegeben hat
was übrigens viele leute als neuer wagen
fanden könnt ihr euch vorstellen dass leute das zwei scheiße fanden zu release
kein witz als das zwei rausgekommen ist fanden es die leute kacke
die haben gesagt so eine uninspirierte kack map damals haben ja auch viele
leute gerne geisel rettung gespielt diese nicht umsonst cs in den maps ich
habe gerne assault gespielt das ist diese map mit dem lüftungsschacht
keine ahnung ob es die noch gibt die map mit dem lüftungsschacht war nice da
konnte man immer den lüftungsschacht campen ja ich kann mich noch daran
erinnern als das zum ersten mal gespielt habe ich war so unglaublich schlecht man
ich habe mich damals angestellt echt wie der letzte mensch was so spiele angeht
ich weiß noch ich glaube dass super mario world auf super nintendo
super mario world auf super nintendo
das kannst du heutzutage easy an einem tag locker durchspielen auch wenn du
kein speedrunner bist innerhalb von ein paar stunden auch wenn du kein speedrunner
bist und auch ohne dass du jetzt nur star star world star road
shortcuts nimmst kannst du easy ein paar stunden durchspielen vielleicht nicht
die komplett ausrute hinten drunter es ist easy ja und das ist auch gar nicht
schwer wenn man heutzutage 20 30 jahre spieler erfahrung hat aber leute ich
sag euch das war echt schwer für mich
damals das war echt schwer ich habe bestimmt weiß ich zwei monate
gebraucht oder so bis ich mal super mario world auf super nintendo durchgespielt
hatte und es war echt schwer aber es aber so danach ging es immer danach ging
das immer besser easy und alles aber das war ja auch eines der ersten so
plattformer die ich gespielt habe ich glaube davor habe ich nur dass das das
das aller allererstes mario spiel was ich gespielt habe glaube ich damals auf dem gameboy
das allererste super mario land was in richtig naja vielleicht jetzt nicht
kack game ist aber kein finde ich heute auch noch kein sonderlich gutes spiel da
wussten sie noch nicht so genau was wir da treiben bei nintendo das zweite war
deutlich besser also meine erste konsole die ich hatte war tatsächlich gameboy
ein game mit tetris und super mario land ich weiß nicht genau wann aber müsste
wahrscheinlich schon so 1900
89 90 oder so gewesen sein wann kam denn wann kam dann der gameboy raus
nah nee dann ein bisschen später dann ein bisschen später dann wahrscheinlich
dann wahrscheinlich eher 1990 oder so da hatten wir relativ schnell super nintendo
erste erstes g super mario world zero war glaube ich dabei ein paar andere sachen
nicht schon später kauft die waren damals mega teuer die spiele ja uns als ich als ich spiele war
die war damals mega teuer die spiele und als ich als ich als ich als ich habe interpretation gemacht
spiel die waren damals mega teuer die spiele ja und als ich als ich als ich habe interpretation thrill
Als ich Link to the Past gespielt habe auf dem Super Nintendo zum ersten Mal, ich war so schlecht.
Ich war so schlecht, ihr müsst euch vorstellen, ich habe tagelang nicht mal das Tutorial geschafft.
Also hier, Escape, wie sich das heute bei den Speedrunner nennt.
Also das Schloss und Escape.
Ich habe es nicht geschafft.
Ich habe es nicht gecheckt.
Da gibt es doch diese Stelle, wo man im Thronsaal diesen Schrank wegschieben muss.
Und ich habe es einfach nicht gecheckt.
Und als ich es endlich gecheckt habe, habe ich mir gedacht, jawohl, geschafft.
Und dann kam dieser ganze Escape durch die Kanalisation da.
Da bin ich so oft verreckt.
Ich hatte fast keinen Bock mehr, das Spiel weiterzuspielen, weil ich so schlecht war damals.
Windwaker ist auch schon 20, kann man sich kaum vorstellen.
Ich war damals immer sad, weil ich kein Gamecube hatte und Windwaker nicht spielen konnte.
Ja, mal gucken, wann sie da die Server abschalten.
Sonic habe ich auch nie geschafft.
Das lag aber wahrscheinlich mit daran, weil ich selbst keine Sega-Konsole hatte, sondern das immer beim Kollegen aus der Schule gespielt habe.
Ich hatte einen Super Nintendo, der hatte das Teil von, was war das, der Mega Drive damals von Sega?
Ich glaube schon.
Und der hatte so eine Sega-Kiste.
Was eigentlich ganz nice war, da konnte man nämlich beigespielen.
Und ich war auch zu unfähig für Sonic.
Ich habe es durchgespielt, ich habe aber auch wieder ewig gebraucht.
Also wie gesagt, ich habe Monate für Super Mario World gebraucht auf Super Nintendo und Link to the Past habe ich auch Monate gespielt, bis ich da durch bin, Mann.
Ich hatte, ich meine, ich war da klein, ne?
Ich hatte übelst Schiss.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, man weiß es.
Link to the Past Release Day, 1993.
Oder sowas, 1991, Alter.
Wie alt war ich denn da?
91, äh, 84 bin ich, 7.
Okay, aber ich hatte es dann ja später, 8.
Ich hatte, ich hatte in, ich hatte Schiss vor der Dark World in der Link to the Past.
Und dementsprechend konnte ich immer nur spielen, wenn meine Mutter dabei war.
Ich hatte, ich hatte übelst Schiss vor den Dark World Dungeons, weil die so gruselig waren mit 8.
Und ich.
Ich bin dann eigentlich hauptsächlich im Dorf rumgelaufen die ganze Zeit und habe dort alles, was es gab, rausgefunden, so.
Ja, das waren echt Zeiten, Mann.
Aber ich habe es durchgespielt.
Nach Wochen, wenn nicht Monaten, die ich dafür gebraucht habe.
Also mein Super Nintendo habe ich noch, ein paar Super Nintendo Spiele habe ich auch noch.
Was ich auch noch habe, ist die N64 Cartridges.
Aber leider habe ich meine N64 nicht mehr.
Was hältst du von Palo Alto?
Ich habe mit Palo Alto persönlich nie was gemacht.
Dort wo ich, äh, letztes Unternehmen wo ich gearbeitet habe, die hatten eine Firewall von Palo Alto.
Ich glaube das ging allen so, wie sie klein waren, dass die bei eigentlich nicht gruseligen Spielen halt übelst Schiss hatten.
Aber das liegt, das liegt an zwei Sachen.
Erstens weil man jung war und auch enorm viel Vorstellungskraft hatte, was das angeht.
Und eine Sache.
Die bei mir bis heute immer noch andauert.
Ich kann mich Vorstellungskraft mäßig in Pixel Games viel besser reinversetzen als in reale Games.
So bescheuert sich das anhört, weil...
Bei dem einen musst du dir ja gar nicht viel vorstellen.
Aber ich glaube gerade das ist es, dass du dir eben nichts selbst drum herum vorstellen musst.
Und bei Pixel Games halt schon.
Weiß ich, habe ich nichts, nichts zu...
Ich habe keine reale Geld für Brettspiele.
Mit meinem Opa habe ich immer Mensch ärgere dich nicht gespielt.
Aber ansonsten mag ich keine Brettspiele.
Gibt es, gibt es, gibt es, ähm...
Brettspielenjoyer.
So, ich muss grad mal auf dem Handy was nachgucken.
Steiner, dankeschön für den Sub.
Gerade eine Ausbildungsstelle gefunden.
Ist das realistisch?
Moment.
Ist das realistisch, folgendes in einer fiesi Ausbildung alles zu lernen?
Kommt mir viel vor.
Weiß ich, lass mal reingucken.
Kann ich das aufmachen?
Ja, okay, kann man aufmachen.
Muss immer ein bisschen vorsichtig sein, weil ich hier im Stream einfach anklicke.
Wer weiß nicht, dass da Bubar gezeigt wird und ich...
krieg Probleme.
Also, Schwerpunkt...
Ähm...
In welchem Kontext ist das jetzt?
Stellenanzeige für...
Also, der Kontext würde mich jetzt schon interessieren.
So fiesi, fiesi Ausbildung und da steht dann irgendwie eine Abteilungs...
Abschnitt drinne, das lernen sie bei uns, oder wie?
Oder wie darf ich mir das vorstellen?
Okay, Schwerpunkt Netzwerktechnik in unserem Online Server Team.
Systemadministration Linux, Windows, Mac.
Ja, allein schon das ist blödsinnig.
Okay, in der Ausbildung ist es nicht ganz so blödsinnig,
weil viele Unternehmen machen das ja so,
dass du in der Ausbildung ein paar Stationen durchgehst
und da kann es durchaus sein,
dass du mal in einem Linux, in einem Windows
und in einem Mac Team landest,
wobei ich wenige Unternehmen kenne,
die das alles gleichermaßen gewichtet haben.
Ja, aber du wirst ja schon relativ schnell feststellen,
dass du auf Windows Kacke findest
und lieber Linux machst.
Gehe ich zumindest mal von aus.
Verwendung von
Virtualisierungstechnologien,
VMware, vSphere, Docker, AWS,
Elastic.
Warum heißt bei Amazon
alles Elastic, Mann?
Können die das...
Das ist die beste bei AWS, ohne Scheiß.
Ich habe mit AWS noch nicht viel gemacht,
aber bei AWS ist alles so super
kryptisch bescheuert benannt.
Okay.
Verwendung von Virtualisierungstechnologien,
VMware, Docker, AWS,
Automatisierung von Installationsprozessen,
Puppet, Vagrant!
Puppet und Vagrant!
Okay, Puppet ist wirklich
outdated, overrated, jebaited.
Es gibt noch ein paar, die das haben,
aber du findest kaum noch Leute dafür.
Ansible ist
the way to go und
Vagrant...
Vagrant ist übrigens von den gleichen
Leuten, die auch Terraform und
Konsul und
Vault
und was haben die noch so alles
gebaut haben.
Vagrant war das allererste Projekt von dem Typ.
Von den Typen.
Aber benutzt... Also mir fällt eigentlich keiner mal ein,
der noch wirklich Vagrant benutzt.
Administration von Storage-Systemen,
NetApp,
Log-Management, Elastic-Stack,
Kibana, Log-Stash.
Warum eigentlich alle drei?
Warum?
Monitoring der Systeme
Checkmk, OMOD.
Was ist OMOD?
O-O? Ne.
OMD.
Monitoring.
Open Monitoring
Distribution.
Ach, das ist Checkmk
als fertiger Installer
oder was?
Metric Beats Plugins.
Administration und Konfiguration von verteilten Datenbanksystemen
per Kona.
Solr.
Ist Solr nicht
Lucene Search Engine Kram?
Administration und
Konfiguration von Key Value Stores,
Redis, Memcache, RapidMQ,
Apache
PHP, FPM.
Administration der internen Netze.
IOS.
Übrigens nicht mit Apple zu verwechseln.
Das Zeug hieß schon IOS, bevor
IOS, IOS war.
Administration der produktiven
und Standard Firewall FortiGuard
FortiGuard PF-Sense.
VPN-Lösung. PF-Sense.
Noch einmal. Load Balancer.
HA-Proxy, F5.
Apache.
Einrichtung, Überwachung von Backup-Lösungen.
Backup PC.
Da haben sie aber auch alles drin.
LVM, Shell-Skripte.
Installern zu konfigurieren.
Warteproduktiv-Lösungs-Server. Installern zu konfigurieren.
Ob der eingesetzt ist.
Konzeption von Server-Architektur,
Störungs- und Problem-Mannesicherung.
Also, Chat.
Ja, das kann man
während der Ausbildung schon alles lernen.
Du wirst es nicht alles im Detail in der Tiefe
lernen, dass du sagst, ich bin ein Experte.
Da drin, da drin, da drin, da drin,
da drin, da drin, da drin.
Aber mach die Themen alle Streifen in der Ausbildung.
Klar, warum nicht.
Ja, da gebe ich euch recht, Chat.
Das liest sich
etwas wildwüchsig, das stimmt.
Aber das kommt wahrscheinlich daher, weil es den Laden schon eine Weile gibt.
Die haben mit Puppet angefangen, sind gerade am Umbauen auf Ansible, haben, ja, das, das, das.
Ich meine, ich bin ja froh, dass hier keine Checkpoint Firewall mehr drin steht.
Kennt den Krempel noch jemand von früher?
Checkpoint Firewall 1.
Ja.
Ich erinnere.
Dunkel, Alter.
Ja, genau so sah das aus, Mann.
So sah das aus.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das jetzt aussieht. Gibt es das überhaupt noch?
Aber man sieht, das ist aber richtig aktuell. Guck mal.
Es wird unterstützt.
Solaris 8.9.10.
Windows 2000, 2003 Server.
Red Hat 3.
Und Nokia IP so.
Keine Ahnung.
Okay, den Kram gibt es ernsthaft immer noch.
Wisst ihr?
Wenn ich auf der Webseite kein Screenshot vom Management Interface sehe, weiß ich, es ist einfach nur Business Enterprise Geschwubbel und Scheiße.
Hey, iCheck.
Na, alles richtig im Detail kann man ja davon gar nicht können.
Historisch gewachsen, genau.
Okay, Leute.
Ich muss jetzt ins Bett gehen.
Schon spät.
Boomer müde.
Boomer schlafen.
Du findest sicherlich was in der Ausbildung, was dich interessiert.
Und dann.
Kannst du den anderen Kram skippen.
Alles klar.
So, Leute.
Ich muss ins Bett.
Wir hören uns.
Bis dann.
Macht's gut.
See you.